>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
A SILENCER CELL PHONES AND
MOBILE DEVICES AT THIS TIME,
THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
PRESIDENT OUATTARA, IT IS A
PLEASURE TO WELCOME YOU AT
COLUMBIA, AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR OUR COMMUNITY FOR
ACCEPTING TO COME AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH US THIS
AFTERNOON.
IT IS ALSO A PLEASURE TO
WELCOME YOU ALL TO THIS COLUMBIA
WORLD LEADERS FORUM EVENT.
AS I HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED, WE
ARE JOINED TODAY BY HIS
EXCELLENCY, DOCTOR ALASSANE
OUATTARAE MINISTER OF CC
D'IVOIRE.
AND MEMBERS OF THE OF ARE IN
THE LITIGATION.
-- MEMBERS OF THE FRE AND A
DELEGATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO START THIS EVENT
OF THE WORLD LEADERS FORUM.
PLEASE, BEFORE INTRODUCING HIS
EXCELLENCY, PRESIDENT OUATTARA,
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE
BRIEFLY, THE WORLD LEADERS FORUM
AND ITS PURPOSE.
THE WORLD LEADERS FORUM WAS
FOUNDED IN 2003 BY OUR PRESIDENT
TO SUPPORT ROBUST DIALOGUE ON
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES FACING
OUR GLOBAL SOCIETY.
FOR 10 YEARS, IT HAS ALLOWED
OUR STUDENTS, FACULTY, AND
STAFF, TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY WITH
THE MEN AND WOMEN INVOLVED IN
ADDRESSING THE MAJOR CHALLENGES
OF THE 21st CENTURY.
BY ALLOWING THE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY TO ENTER INTO A
CONVERSATION WITH LEADERS WHO
ARE GRAPPLING WITH MAJOR
CHALLENGES ON THE INTERNATIONAL
STAGE, THE WORLD LEADERS FORUM
ALLOWS COLUMBIA TO FULFILL ONE
OF ITS MOST IMPORTANT DUTIES AS
A GLOBAL CENTER OF LEARNING.
WE TAKE AS AN ARTICLE OF FAITH,
THAT ONLY THROUGH A FREE
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS WILL A
SOLUTION BE FOUND TO THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS FACING SOCIETY.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT WILL
BE DIFFICULT, IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE,
TO REPLICATE IN OTHER -- ANY
OTHER CITY OR ANY OTHER
UNIVERSITY.
COLUMBIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN AMONG
THE MOST INTERNATIONAL
INSTITUTION IN THE MOST
INTERNATIONAL AMERICAN CITY.
WE HAVE THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE
OF GRADUATE AND UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS DRAWN FROM FOREIGN
MISSIONS.
WE HAVE SPENT THE LAST FOUR
YEARS CREATING A NETWORK OF
GLOBAL CENTERS IN EIGHT CITIES.
PARIS, ISTANBUL, AMMAN, NAIROBI,
MUMBAI, SAN DIEGO, AND RIO DE
JANEIRO.
OUR MISSION DEMANDS A GLOBAL
PERSPECTIVE, AND DISCUSSION --
DISCUSSIONS LIKE THE ONE WE ARE
ABOUT TO HAVE TODAY ARE THE
CORNERSTONE OF THIS PURSUIT.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
AGAIN PRESIDENT OUATTARA BEFORE
I INTRODUCE HIM.
DOCTOR ALASSANE OUATTARA IS THE
FIFTH PRESIDENT OF THE REPUBLIC
OF CC
E D'IVOIRE.
HE WAS ELECTED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 2000 10 WHICH IS THE
FIFTH TIME IN 2010.
AN ECONOMIST BY TRAINING, HE
HOLDS A BACHELORS DEGREE IN
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION FROM
DREXEL INSTITUTE OF TECHNOLOGY
IN PHILADELPHIA.
A MASTERS DEGREE AND A PHD IN
ECONOMICS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA IN PHILADELPHIA.
IN 1968, HE JOINED THE
INTERNATIONAL MONETARY FUND
WHERE HE HELD POSITIONS OF
INCREASING RESPONSIBILITIES,
AND LATER JOINED THE CENTRAL
BANK OF WEST AFRICAN STATES,
BCEAO , WHERE AT AGE 40, HE
BECAME THE DEPUTY GOVERNOR AND
LATER GOVERNOR OF THE BANK.
IN APRILE 990, WHILE CC
D'IVOIRE WAS HIT BY AN
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS, DOCTOR
ALASSANE OUATTARA WAS APPOINTED
BY LATE PRESIDENT AS CHAIRMAN
OF THE INTERMINISTERIAL
COMMITTEE FOR COORDINATION OF
THE STABILIZATION PROGRAM AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
A FEW MONTHS LATER, HE WAS
APPOINTEE D'IVOIRE'S
FIRST PRIME MINISTER AND HEAD
OF GOVERNMENT, UNTIL DECEMBER
1993.
HE THEN RETURNED TO THE IMF
WHERE HE SERVED AS A DEPUTY
MANAGING DIRECTOR, THE HIGHEST
POSITION HELD BY AN AFRICAN IN
THIS INSTITUTION TO DATE.
FOLLOWING HIS RICH INTERNATIONAL
CAREER, DOCTOR OUATTARA
RETURNED HOME IN 1990 TO TAKE
OVER THE PRESIDENCY OF ONE OF
CC
E D'IVOIRE IS A MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTIES, RDR, IN 2010.
DOCTOR OUATTARA RUN -- WON THE
ELECTION WITH 54.10% OF THE
VOTES.
PRESIDENT OUATTARA IS
CONSIDERED AS THE FATHER OF THE
NEW EMERE D'IVOIRE.
HE INTRODUCED MANY ECONOMIC
REFORMS THAT HAVE TRANSFORMED
CC
E D'IVOIRE, AND IMPROVE
LIVELIHOOD OF MILLIONS OF
IVORIANS.
UNDER PRESIDENT OUATTARA'S
LEADERSHE D'IVOIRE
BECAME THE THIRD FASTEST
GROWING ECONOMY IN AFRICA.
BASED ON SUCH ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND SOCIAL PROGRESS EXPERIENCED
DURING HIS FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
TERM, PRESIDENT OUATTARA WAS
REELECTED FOR A SECOND TERM IN
OCTOBER 2015 ON THE FIRST ROUND
OF ELECTIONS, WITH 83.66
PERCENT OF THE VOTES.
TWO THIS OFFICIAL BIOGRAPHY, I
HAVE JUST READ, I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD TWO IMPORTANT ELEMENTS TO
HIGHLIGHT FROM A HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE, AS I AM A
HISTORIAN, THE CONTRIBUTION OF
PRESIDENT OUATTARA TO THE RECENT
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC HISTORY
OF AFRICA.
FIRST, HIS PERSISTENCE IN
REMAINING IN THE PUBLIC SPHERE,
WHICH HAS BEEN CRITICIZED, HAS
PROVEN THAT AFRICANS ARE NOT
ALWAYS CAUGHT IN THE TRAPS OF
POLITICAL TRIBALISM.
DESPITE THE LEGAL MANEUVERS AND
OF VIOLENCE AIMED AT EXCLUDING
HIM UNDER THE ACCUSATION THAT
HE WAS NOT AN IVORIAN, HE WON
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION. 10
YEARS OF PROPAGANDA AGAINST
QUOTE THIS STRANGER WAS
DECISIVELY DENIED AT THE POLLS.
SECOND, THE SUCCESS STORY OF
THE CC
E D'IVOIRE ECONOMY HAS
BEEN ATTRIBUTE IT TO HIS
POLICIES AND REFORMS.
THOUGH WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY
OBLIGATED TO SHARE HIS LIBERAL
AND GLOBALIZING CONCEPTION OF
THE GOVERNANCE OF ECONOMY, WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT HE HAS
SUCCEEDED IN RESTORING THE
ECONOMY E D'IVOIRE
SUCCESSFULLY AS THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
STABILIZATION PROGRAM AND AS
PRIME MINISTER OF THE GOVERNMENT
IN THE MID-90s, AND AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE REPUBLIC OF
CC
E D'IVOIRE SINCE 2010.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
PRESIDENT, IS THAT HE AN ACT
THE MIRAE D'IVOIRE IN
THE CONTEXT WHEN WE DISCUSS
ABOUT THE FUTURE, BUT ALSO TO
RECONCILE IVORIANS AFTER THE
CRISIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING OUR INVITATION TO
DISCUSS WITH US YOUR EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE AND GRASP
OF THE CONSTRAINED OPPORTUNITY
OF THE AFRICAN CONTINENT,
POSITIONING YOU AS ONE OF THE
BEST INTERLOCUTORS ON THE
CONVERSATION OF GLOBAL AFRICAN
AND IVORIAN ISSUES.
I AM SURE THAT YOU WILL LEND
YOURSELF WITH GOOD GRACE TO
QUESTIONS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
EXCELLENCY, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
DESPITE THANK YOU.
--
>>, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR DIOUF.
FACULTY, HONORABLE EXIST, BUT
-- HONORABLE GUESTS, DEAR
STUDENTS, AND MEMBERS OF THE
DELEGATION, MY DELEGATION I
THINK IS COMING FROM A MEETING
OF THE GENERAL ASSEMBLY, SO
THERE ARE MANY OF THEM HERE.
IF I WERE TO INTRODUCE THEM, IT
WOULD TAKE A GOOD HALF AN HOUR,
BUT WE HAVE THE FIRST LADY,
DOMINIQUE, THE SECRETARY-
GENERAL OF THE PRESIDENCY,
MINISTER OF INTEGRATION,
MINISTER OF HEALTH, MINISTER OF
PETROLEUM, MINISTER OF PLANNING,
MINISTER OF SOLIDARITY, THE
AMBASSADOR, CHIEF OF STAFF OF
THE PRESIDENCY, SPECIAL ADVISOR
OF MEDICATIONS, SHALL I
CONTINUE?
[ LAUGHTER ] KNOW I SHOULD NOT.
BUT IT IS A REAL PRO LEISURE --
PLEASURE TO BE BACK IN A
UNIVERSITY ENVIRONMENT. I MYSELF
STUDIED IN THE STATES A FEW
DECADES AGO.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE STUDENTS FOR BEING
HERE, AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
THREE IVORIANS. MAYBE THEY ARE
NOT HERE, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM, AS GOD WHO IS
A BACHELOR OF ARTS IN IN
FINANCE.
HE IS HERE.
IT IS NICE TO SEE YOU.
AND, WE HAVE IBIS WHO IS A PHD
IN HISTORY.
I DON'T THINK HE IS HERE.
APPARENTLY HE IS TRAVELING
BETWEEN COLUMBIA, YALE, HARVARD.
A BRILLIANT PROFESSOR, SO I AM
VERY HAPPY TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM.
AND NIKITA HERE IS AN MBA. I
WOULD GIVE YOU A BRIEF
PRESENTATION ON THE CHALLENGES
FOR SUCCESSFUL DEMOGRAPHIC
TRANSITION AND REACHING
AFRICA'S POTENTIAL TO GIVE YOU
THE CASEE D'IVOIRE.
OBVIOUSLY, I COULD TAKE A GOOD
HALF AN HOUR SPEAKING ABOUT
THIS, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE
BRIEF.
AND, TO TELL YOU THAT THIS IS
QUITE A CHALLENGE.
FOUR AFRICANS, AND AFRICA.
BECAUSE, OUR POPULATION TODAY
IS 1.2 BILLION.
IT IS GROWING VERY FAST, AND IN
ABOUT 33 YEARS, BY 2050, AFRICA
WILL ACCOUNT FOR ONE FOURTH OF
THE WORLD POPULATION.
IT WILL HAVE THE YOUNGEST
POPULATION IN THE WORLD.
SO, THIS IS CLEARLY A MAJOR
CHALLENGE FOR GOVERNMENTS, FOR
THE PEOPLE OF AFRICA, AND FOR
THE WORLD, I WOULD SAY.
AND ALSO, IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY, WITH A YOUNG
POPULATION, IT MEANS, I THINK,
STRONGER MANPOWER, AND ALSO THE
CHANCES OF ACCELERATING
TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION.
AFRICA OF COURSE 20 YEARS AGO
WAS SEEN AS A HOPELESS
CONTINENT, BY ECONOMISTS, AND
TODAY THIS HAS USUALLY CHANGED.
IT WAS ABOUT 10 YEARS AGO
AFRICA IS RISING, AND BECAUSE
OUR PROGRESS HAS BEEN QUITE
IMPRESSIVE.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS DUE TO A LOT
OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW I WILL
NOT INSIST BUT BECAUSE OF
ABUNDANT NATURAL RESOURCES IN
THE CONTINENT, AND WE HAVE
ACHIEVED THE STRONGEST GROWTH
RATE IN THE WORLD OVER THE PAST
10 YEARS OR SO.
THE PAST THREE YEARS HAVE BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT, BUT CLEARLY, WE
HAVE BEEN MUCH ABOVE THE GROWTH
RATES OF THE OECD COUNTRIES.
THIS IS A CHALLENGE I WAS
SITTING BECAUSE AT THIS PACE IN
TERMS OF POPULATION GROWTH, BY
2050, NIGERIA WILL BE THE THIRD
MOST POPULATED COUNTRY. AFTER
CHINA AND INDIA, AND AHEAD OF
THE UNITED STATES IN TERMS OF
POPULATION.
IF MY RECOLLECTION IS RIGHT,
ETHIOPIA AND CONGO AND KINSHASA
WILL ALSO BE AMONG THE 10 MOST
POPULATED COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
SO, THIS SHOWS HOW MUCH
POTENTIAL THERE IS IN TERMS OF
DEMOGRAPHY.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS WOULD REQUIRE
THAT GOVERNMENTS DEVELOP
POLICIES WHICH CAN CREATE JOBS
AND ABSORB THE YOUNG POPULATION
AND AVOID SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY, AT THE UN, THE QUESTION
OF MIGRATION OF THE YOUNGER
THROUGH THE REGION, NOT BEING
ALLOWED TO REACH EUROPE.
THIS IS A CHALLENGE THAT WE CAN
TRY TO MEET, BUT IT IS NOT
EASY.
I THINK IT IS OUR RESPONSE
ABILITY.
AND, IF WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT
POLICIES, I THINK IT WILL BE A
PROBLEM NOT ONLY FOR AFRICA,
BUT FOR THE WORLD AT LARGE.
AS I SAID, GIVING THE QUESTION
OF MIGRATION AS AN EXAMPLE.
TODAY, WE HAD A LUNCH WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND SOME OTHER
HEADS OF STATES, AND THESE WERE
THE ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED
WITH HIM TO GET A BIT MORE
PRECISION ON HIS VISION FOR
AFRICA.
AND, THE POLICIES OF THE UNITED
STATES IN THE YEARS TO COME.
NOW, I THINK AS WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE PROGRESS, WE NEED TO ENSURE
POLITICAL STABILITY, PEACE, AND
SECURITY.
AND, CC
E D'IVOIRE IS A CLEAR
EXAMPLE OF THIS.
WE HAD NEARLY 4 DECADES OF
PEACE AND TRANQUILITY FROM
INDEPENDENCE IN 1962 2000,
ALTHOUGH A FEW YEARS BEFORE
THAT, WE HAD PROBLEMS.
BUT THE WORST WAS BETWEEN 2000
AND 2010, WHEN THE COUNTRIES
WENT THROUGH MADNESS, I WOULD
SAY.
CLEARLY WE NEED TO STRENGTHEN
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS, AND
THIS IS BEING DONE NOT ONLY IN
CC
E D'IVOIRE BUT IN SENEG
AND ALSO NIGERIA.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
LEADERS MAKE ENOUGH INVESTMENTS
IN THE MAJOR SECTORS, SOCIAL
SECTORS, OF HEALTH AND GOOD
EDUCATION, PARTICULARLY THE
EDUCATION OF GIRLS.
AND, WE NEED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT WELL-DESIGNED
NATIONAL POLICIES WHICH WE ARE
DOING INE D'IVOIRE, AND
LATER ON I WILL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF OUR PERFORMANCE ON
THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL FIELD.
MANY OF THE AFRICAN COUNTRIES
ARE AMONG THE BEST PERFORMERS
IN THE WORLD BANK BUSINESS
REPORT, AND I THINK THIS IS
QUITE A WELCOME DEVELOPMENT FOR
OUR CONTINENT.
ONE THING WE ALL AGREE TODAY,
ALONG WITH THE HEAD OF STATES
WITH HIM WE MET, IS THAT WE
NEED TO ACCELERATE THE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE DOMESTIC MOBILIZATION
OF RESOURCES.
BECAUSE, WE NEED TO FINANCE
LARGE-SCALE REGIONAL PROJECTS,
NOT ONLY IN TRANSPORT ROLES,
BUT IN POWER AND ENERGY, AND
THIS IS SOMETHING WHICH IS A
CHALLENGE FOR MANY AFRICAN
COUNTRIES.
BASICALLY, ONE THING WHICH IS
NOT WORKING VERY WELL, ON THE
CONTINENT IS ECONOMIC AND
AGGRESSION.
WE NEED TO DEEPEN ORIGINAL
INTEGRATION, AND I AM PROUD TO
SAY THAT THIS IS A REALITY IN
WEST AFRICA WITH THE ECONOMIC
COMMUNITY OF WEST AFRICAN STATES
WITH A COMMUNITY ACCOUNTING FOR
MORE THAN 300 MILLION PEOPLE,
AND ALSO THE REGIONAL MONETARY
AND ECONOMIC UNION OF WEST
AFRICA, OF 100 MILLION PEOPLE,
WHERE CLEARLY THERE IS A GOOD
COORDINATION OF ECONOMIC
POLICIES AND FREE MOVEMENT OF
GOODS AND PEOPLE AMONG THE
COUNTRIES.
CLEARLY E D'IVOIRE IS A
CHAMPION OF THIS, BECAUSE IN
TRAFFIC AND TRADE, THE TRADE WE
HAVE WITH OTHER AFRICAN
COUNTRIES ACCOUNT FOR ONE THIRD
OF OUR TOTAL TRAITS, WHERE IT
IS BETWEEN 12 -- 10 AND 12
PERCENT IN WEST AFRICA.
THE INTEGRATION IS ESSENTIAL IF
WE WANT TO MAKE MORE PROGRESS
TO ABSORB THIS LARGER
DEMOGRAPHIC GROWTH.
NOW, LET ME SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT CCE D'IVOIRE, AS
PROFESSOR DIOUF SAID, THIS IS A
CONVERSATION, SO I DON'T WANT
TO READ YOU A SPEECH, BUT I DO
WANT TO REDO A FEW WORDS ABOUT
CC
E D'IVOIRE, AND THEN I
RECEIVE YOUR QUESTIONS.
CC
E D'IVOIRE HAS A CENTRA
PLACE IN WEST AFRICA.
WE HAVE THE LARGEST COUNTRY IN
NIGERIA WITH 175 MILLION PEOPLE
OUT OF 300 MILLION OR MORE.
THEN YOU HAVE THE OTHER BLOCK
OF COUNTRIES ESSENTIALLY, THE
FORMER FRENCH SPEAKING COUNTRIES
WHICH WERE MENTIONED ACCOUNTING
FOR ABOUT 100 MILLION.
OF THAT E D'IVOIRE IS
CLEARLY AN IMPORTANT PARTNER,
BECAUSE IT ACCOUNTS FOR MORE
THAN 35% OF THE GDP, AND SO
FORTH.
IN FACT, DURING THE 10 YEARS OF
CRISIS, THERE WERE NO
INVESTMENT, AND IT DROPPED TO
10% AND 9% OF GDP WHILE GROWTH
WAS CLOSE TO ZERO AND
POPULATION GROWTH HAD BEEN MORE
THAN 2% PER YEAR.
SO THAT MEANS THAT DURING THOSE
10 YEARS, THE RATE OF POVERTY
INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY, FROM
WHAT IT WAS DURING THE PERIOD
90 TO 93, WHEN I WAS PRIME
MINISTER.
AND, WHEN WE WERE ELECTED AFTER
4 1/2 MONTHS IN THE GULF HOTEL,
SURROUNDED BY THE TROOPS OF THE
PREVIOUS PRESIDENT, WE DEVELOPED
POLICIES, WHAT WE CALLED A
PRESIDENTIAL PROGRAM OF URGENCY.
SO, WHEN WE GOT OUT OF THE GULF
HOTEL, WE STARTED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM,
SO ACTUALLY, BEING HELD
HOSTAGES FOR 4 1/2 MONTHS, WAS
NOT PLEASANT, BUT IT WAS USEFUL
FOR THE COUNTRY, SINCE WE USED
THE TIME TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
MY TEAM AT ANY TIME.
SOMETIMES I WOULD CALL THEM AT
MIDNIGHT AND TELL THEM I HAVE
AN IDEA, LET'S WORK ON IT.
SO IT FELT AS THOUGH I WAS BACK
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
I ENJOYED VERY MUCH THIS.
DESPITE THE STRESS WE WENT
THROUGH.
BUT OUR PRIORITIES WERE CLEAR,
AND I THINK THE ACHIEVEMENTS
ALSO.
YOU MENTIONED, PROFESSOR, THAT
WE HAVE HELD DEMOCRATIC
ELECTIONS, AND WE HAVE SET UP A
NEW CONSTITUTION LAST YEAR,
WHICH NOW PROVIDES LIKE THE
UNITED STATES, TICKETS FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
WITH THE IDEA OF STRENGTHENING
THE REGIONS OF THE COUNTRY,
BECAUSE CLEARLY, THE DRAW OF
GETTING AND KEEPING POWER IS SO
STRONG IN AFRICA, I THINK IT IS
GOOD TO HAVE POWER-SHARING SO
THAT IT WILL NOT DESTABILIZE
COUNTRIES.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHICH I
PERSONALLY FELT WAS IN PORTON
FOR MY COUNTRY, AND THIS IS
WHAT IS IN PLACE IN SOUTH
AFRICA AND NIGERIA.
IT IS NOT SOMETHING USUAL IN
THE FRANCOPHONE COUNTRIES, SO I
MUST SAY WE GOT A LOT OF
CRITICISM, BUT I AM SURE WITH
TIME PEOPLE WILL SEE THAT THIS
IS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTION TO THE
FUTURE STABILITY OF MY COUNTRY.
IN TERMS OF ACHIEVEMENTS IN THE
ECONOMIC POLICIES, WE HAVE OVER
THE FIVE YEARS OF 2012 TO 2016,
AN AVERAGE ANNUAL GROWTH RATE
OF 9%, WHICH IS, SOMETIMES 10%
SOMETIMES AT PRESENT, BUT ON
AVERAGE 9%, WHICH IS AMONG THE
10 HIGHEST GROWING COUNTRIES IN
THE WORLD.
THIS ALLOWED US IN A FIVE-YEAR
PERIOD TO INCREASE OUR GDP BY
50%, AND REDUCE RADICALLY THE
LEVEL OF POVERTY, ALTHOUGH NOT
SUFFICIENTLY. WE WERE ABLE TO
DO THIS THROUGH GOOD
MACROECONOMIC POLICY, IN TERMS
OF KEEPING A LOW DEFICIT AND
DEBT AT A NORMAL LEVEL, AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE MADE A
STRUCTURAL REFORMS NECESSARY
FOR THE COUNTRY.
IN FACT, THE WORLD BANK
CONSIDERED THAT WE WERE AMONG
42 CONSECUTIVE YEARS, THE BEST
AND MOST REFORMING COUNTRIES IN
THE WORLD, ACCORDING TO THE
WORLD BANK DOING BUSINESS
REPORTS.
THIS GOOD PERFORMANCE WAS ALSO
DUE TO VARIOUS INVESTMENT CODES
WHICH WE IMPROVED.
THE MINING CODE, THE PETROLEUM
CODE, THE GENERAL INVESTMENT
CODE AND SO FORTH.
AS A RESULT OF THE INCREASING
INVESTMENTS TO GDP, WHICH WAS
AT 9% IN 2011 WAS AT 20% IN
2016.
SO IT MORE THAN DOUBLED.
THIS OF COURSE EXPLAINS WHY THE
GROWTH RATE HAS BEEN SO HIGH.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE PUT A LOT
OF EMPHASIS ON SOCIAL
EXPENDITURES.
HEALTH AND EDUCATION.
THIS ALLOWED THE RATE OF POVERTY
TO DROP SUBSTANTIALLY DURING
THIS PERIOD AND OF COURSE, WE
MADE GOOD PROGRESS ON
EMPLOYMENT, ESPECIALLY YOUTH
EMPLOYMENT, AND WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF THAT.
IN TERMS OF SOCIAL EXPENDITURE,
WE NOW MAKE SURE THAT ONE THIRD
OF THE BUDGET IS DEVOTED TO
SOCIAL EXPENDITURES, AND HEALTH
AND EDUCATION, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY, WE GIVE SO MUCH
EMPHASIS TO PRIVATE INVESTMENT,
AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS THE
MAIN ENGINE OF GROWTH.
SO THE PUBLIC CENTER, THE
GOVERNMENT CAN EMPHASIZE AND
FOCUS ON CONCENTRATING SOCIAL
EXPENDITURE.
SO, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS I WANTED TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
AND, TO SAY ALSO, THAT ON
IMPROVING HEALTH AND EDUCATION,
IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE TRIED TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
ELECTRICITY. FOR EXAMPLE, WE
WERE ABLE TO RAISE PRODUCTION
TO ABOUT 40% BY 2016.
AND, MY OBJECTIVE IS TO BE ABLE
TO RAISE THIS TO 4000 MW BY
2020.
CC
E D'IVOIRE IS A COUNTRY
WHERE THE RATE OF ELECTRICITY
BEING CUT PER YEAR IS THE
LOWEST IN AFRICA.
ABOUT FOUR YEARS AGO, SOUTH
AFRICA AND CAPE VERDE WERE
AHEAD OF US.
I THINK IT IS NOW 16 HOURS PER
YEAR OF LACK OF ELECTRICITY,
WHICH MEANS ABOUT ONE HOUR PER
MONTH FOR THE WHOLE COUNTRY
WHERE YOU HAVE ELECTRICITY.
IF YOU GO TO SOME COUNTRIES I
WILL NOT NAME, YOU WILL SEE
THAT THE LACK OF ELECTRICITY IS
ABOUT 20 HOURS PER DAY.
SO, THIS IS CLEARLY A MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT.
AND SO, IN TERMS OF PRODUCTION,
WE WERE ABLE IN FIVE YEARS,
THANKS TO THE MINISTER OF
PUBLIC PRODUCTION, WE WERE ABLE
TO DEVELOP THE PRODUCTION OF
PORTABLE WATER COMPARED TO THE
50 YEARS PRIOR TO OUR ARRIVAL.
MUCH PROGRESS WAS MADE IN MANY
AREAS WHERE YOU DID NOT HAVE
WATER, SO WE WERE ABLE TO
IMPROVE THIS, AND REBUILT A LOT
OF CLASSROOMS AND SO FORTH AND
SO ON.
I DON'T WANT TO STAY LONGER ON
THIS PERFORMANCE, SO JUST TO
SAY THAT BASICALLY, AS OF TODAY,
THE ECONOMY IS IN VERY GOOD
SHAPE, DESPITE THE DROP IN THE
WORLD PRICE OF COCOA, PROBABLY
YOU KNOWE D'IVOIRE
ACCOUNTS FOR 40% OF THE WORLD'S
COCOA PRODUCTION, SO ANY TIME
YOU READ A PIECE OF CHOCOLATE,
THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE THAT 40%
OF IT COE D'IVOIRE.
SO, WE ARE THE PRIMARY PRODUCER
OF COCOA, AND THE PRICE OF
COCOA DROPPED FROM -- DROPPED
BY 25 TO 30% THIS PAST YEAR,
AND THIS OBVIOUSLY NEEDED
ADJUSTMENT.
WE ALSO HAD STRIKES, AND
ADJUSTMENTS WITH THE SECURITY
FORCES WHICH NEEDED MORE
EXPENDITURES.
BUT I TOLD PEOPLE, THIS IS THE
RESULT OF MORE GROWTH AND MORE
WEALTH, BECAUSE EVERYONE WANTS
TO GET A SHARE, AND AS A RESULT,
YOU HAVE TO GET INTO A DIALOGUE
TO ACCOMMODATE THESE SITUATIONS.
AS OF TODAY, THE SITUATION IS
QUITE GOOD.
PROSPECTS ARE GOOD, AND WE
THINK THAT OUR GROWTH RATE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE VERY
HIGH, 7 TO 8% OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS UNTIL 2020.
SO THIS, PROFESSORS AND MEMBERS
OF THE FACULTY, IS A SOME OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF MY
PRESENTATION I WANTED TO GIVE
YOU, AND I WANTED TO TELL YOU
HOW MUCH THE DEMOGRAPHIC GROWTH
IS HIGH IN AFRICA.
IT IS A GOOD THING.
IT IS A CHALLENGE.
BUT, CC
E D'IVOIRE TODAY HAS 20
MILLION, AND BY 2050 WILL HAVE
MORE THAN 50 MILLION.
BY 2100, WE WILL HAVE MORE THAN
100 MILLION, WHICH IS A LARGER
POPULATION THAN THAT OF FRANCE.
AS I SAID, NIGERIA BY 2050 WILL
BE THE THIRD LARGEST POPULATED
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, AND WITH
A FUTURE OF KINSHASA WHICH WILL
EACH HAVE BETWEEN 400 AND 350
MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS MEANS THAT WE OFFICIALS
HAVE TO DO OUR BEST TO HAVE
GOOD POLICIES AND TO BE OPEN TO
TRADE, WORLD TRADE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE IMPLEMENT
THE RIGHT POLICY, SO THAT THE
JOB CREATION IS A REALITY,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
SO, PROFESSORS, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, WE HAVE SOME ELEMENTS
HERE.
>> [ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
EXCELLENCY FOR A VERY CLEAR AND
DETAILED PRESENTATION, WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS ISSUES THAT ARE BOTH
GLOBAL AND AS I WAS SITTING
AFRICAN AND IVORIAN.
FOR THE Q AND A, I WOULD LIKE
TO SET RULES TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS TO ASK A
QUESTION WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
ASK IT, AND WE WILL GIVE HIS
EXCELLENCY THE TIME TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION.
SO, YOU HAVE, I THINK, TO
MICROPHONES IN THE AISLES.
THE IDEA IS THAT IF YOU WANT TO
ASK A QUESTION, YOU CAN LINE UP
BEHIND ONE OF THE MICROPHONES,
AND I WILL CALL ON YOU, AND YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO ASK YOUR
QUESTION.
SO, THE TWO MICROPHONES ARE
THERE, SO THE FLOOR IS OPEN.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK YOU TO DO, WHEN YOU COME TO
ASK A QUESTION, IS TO STATE
YOUR NAME, AND WHAT SCHOOL YOU
ARE STUDYING FROM.
>> HELLO YOUR EXCELLENCY, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR
REMARKS WITH US AND FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO BE WITH US THIS
EVENING.
MY NAME IS RACHEL McAULEY, I AM
AN ALUMNA OF UNIVERSITY OF
COLUMBIA SCHOOL OF
INTERNATIONAL PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
I STUDIED ECONOMIC AND
POLITICAL DEVELOPMENT AND I'M
NOW WORKING FOR AN AFRICAN
BUSINESS COMPANY BASED HERE IN
NEW YORK.
YOU SPOKE A LITTLE BIT OF CC
D'IVOIRE'S COCOA PRODUCTION,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR A
LITTLE MORE ABOUT AGRICULTURE
AND SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
AFRICAN COUNTRIES CAN DO TO
MAKE HIMSELF GLOBAL PLAYERS IN
PRODUCTION.
WE KNOW THAT AFRICA IS HOME TO
A LOT OF THE WORLD'S ARABLE
LAND BUT PRODUCES -- ARABLE
LAND BUT PRODUCES ONLY A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE WORLD'S GLOBAL
FOOD SUPPLY.
SO WHAT ARE THE INSTITUTIONS
YOU NEED TO BE PUT IN PLACE TO
MAKE THE WORLD -- TO IMPACT THE
WORLD FOOD PRODUCTION?
>> WE CAN TAKE TWO QUESTIONS.
>> HI, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS BECAUSE A SAKE.
I AM A FACULTY MEMBER HERE IN
COLUMBIA, A TEACHER EAST ASIAN
SECURITY, AND AND ALSO A
DIRECTOR OF A GROUP CALLED
DISTANCE MITIGATION FOR AFRICA.
SO I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS, ONE IS
ABOUT CORRUPTION, AND ONE IS
ABOUT THE TRIBAL DIVIDE.
IT SOUNDE D'IVOIRE IS
OVERCOMING VERY WELL, WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN YOUR ECONOMIC GRO
SO, I WONDER HOW YOU ARE
DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES IN
AFRICA?
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST QUESTION
CONCERNING COCOA, YES, WE ARE
THE FIRST WORLD PRODUCER OF
COCOA, BUT, I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT WE ARE ALSO THE
FIRST WORLD PRODUCER OF CASHEW
NOTES -- CASHEW NUTS OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS OVERTAKING INDIA
WHICH WAS THE PREVIOUS TOP
PRODUCER.
WE ARE ALSO THE FIRST AFRICAN
PRODUCER OF BANANAS, AND THE
FIRST AFRICAN PRODUCER OF
PINEAPPLE, AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON.
SO THIS E OWS THAT CC
D'IVOIRE HAS A VERY VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AGRICULTURE PUT
-- AGRICULTURAL POLICY.
AS WAS INTIMATED BY OUR FIRST
PRESIDENT, AND WE NEED TO BE
THANKFUL TO HIM, BECAUSE WHEN
YOU SEE FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS, THE PRODUCT THAT OIL-
PRODUCING COUNTRIES ARE HAVING,
HAVING PUT EMPHASIS ON
AGRICULTURE AND THE
DIVERSIFICATION OF AGRICULTURE
IS A BLESSING.
DESPITE THE DROP IN THE PRICE
OF COCOA, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
A GROWTH RATE OF 7% THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS CLEARLY SOMETHING
OUTSTANDING.
I BELIEVE THAT FOR ALL THESE
PRODUCTS, WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WHICH HAS AS
A COUNTERPART, THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CONSUMER PRODUCTS LIKE RICE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE A SELF-
SUFFICIENCY RICE PRODUCTION
PROGRAM, WHICH BY NEXT YEAR OR
THE YEAR AFTER, WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE ENOUGH RICE FOR
OUR DOMESTIC CONSUMPTION, AND
EVEN BE ABLE TO EXPORT IT TO
SOME OF THE NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES, WHILE THREE OR FOUR
YEARS AGO, WE USED TO IMPORT
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE RICE
CONSUMPTION.
WE ARE ALSO DOING A LOT TO
IMPROVE THE PRODUCTION OF
VEGETABLES AND TOMATOES AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON, SO WE THINK
THAT CLEARLY THIS IS GOING TO
BE A FOCUS OF OUR POLICY TO
DEVELOP AGRICULTURE NOT ONLY FOR
EXPORT, BUT FOR OUR DOMESTIC
CONSUMPTION.
WE INTEND TO REMAIN A MAJOR
AGRICULTURE ECONOMY.
WE ARE ALSO INCREASING VERY
SHARPLY THE PRODUCTION OF GOLD,
FOR EXAMPLE.
WE ARE NOW AT 30 TONS OF GOLD
PRODUCTION, WHERE WE WERE AT
LESS THAN 10 FIVE YEARS AGO.
PETROLEUM PRODUCTION IS ALSO
RISING.
AND WE HAVE OTHER MINERALS
WHICH ARE BEING EXPLOITED, BUT
WE BELIEVE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AGRICULTURE
CONTINUES TO BE THE MAINSTREAM
OF OUR POLICY.
NOW, ON THE QUESTION OF THE
CORRUPTION AND TRADE DIVIDE,
THIS IS A ISSUE FOR ALL
COUNTRIES, BECAUSE AS PEOPLE
SAID, TO HAVE CORRUPTION, YOU
ALSO NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE AND
SYSTEMS THAT ENCOURAGE
CORRUPTION.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN VERY
TOUGH ON THIS ISSUE OF
CORRUPTION, I AGREE THAT
BECAUSE OF 10 YEARS OF BAD
GOVERNANCE IN MY COUNTRY, FROM
2000 TO 2010, IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT INITIALLY IN OUR
ORGANIZATION, BUT WE TOOK A LOT
OF MEASURES, INCLUDING THE
GOVERNANCE OF WEALTH.
BUT, WE DO HOLD THE PRIVATE
SECTOR ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THE
PROBLEM OF CORRUPTION IS LESS
DEFINITE THAN IT WAS A FEW
YEARS BACK, BUT OF COURSE IT IS
NOT WIPED OUT.
NOT THE WAY I WOULD LIKE TO,
PERSONALLY.
BUT, WE WILL CONTINUE ON THIS.
ON THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
DIVIDE, YOU ARE RIGHT, THIS HAS
BEEN THEE AJOR PROBLEM OF CC
D'IVOIRE.
THIS COUNTRY HAS HAD LIBERAL
POLICIES IN THE ECONOMIC FIELD,
BUT OPENNESS ALSO IN TERMS OF
THE POPULATION INTAKE.
AS A RESE D'IVOIRE HAS
24 MILLION PEOPLE, BUT OUT OF
THE 6 MILLION FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES, THAT MEANS IT IS 25%
OF THE POPULATION ARE EXTRA
NATIONALS.
AT SOME STAGE, IF THIS IS
EXPLOITED POLITICALLY, THIS
PRESENTS A PROBLEM. WHAT WE
WENT THROUGH DURING A PERIOD
WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO USE THIS
POLITICALLY, BUT NOW THE
POLITICAL CODE HAS BEEN
IMPROVED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF THOSEE HO ARE BORN IN CC
D'IVOIRE BEFORE INDEPENDENCE
ARE CONSIDERED IVORIAN. AND
THEIR PARENTS WHO WERE BORN IN
CC
E D'IVOIRE BEFORE INDEPT
-- INDEPENDENCE AND SO FORTH,
SO WE TRIED TO IMPROVE THE
NATURALIZATION PROCESS SO THAT
WE GET PEOPLE WHO CAN MAKE A
GOOD CONTRIBUTION TO THE ECONOMY
AND THE COUNTRY TO HAVE A
FOREIGN NATIONALITY, WITHOUT
MUCH PROBLEM.
SO, WE ALSO HAVE A NEW
CONSTITUTION, FOR EXAMPLE
INDICATES THAT TO BE A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE, YOU HAVE
IVORIAN DISSENT BY ONE OF YOUR
PARENTS, WHEREAS THE PREVIOUS
CONSTITUTION USED TO SAY THAT
YOU HAD TO PROVE THAT YOUR
FATHER, GRANDFATHER AND GREAT
GREAT GREAT GREAT FATHERS ARE
ALL FROME D'IVOIRE.
WHEREAS E D'IVOIRE ONLY
EXISTED SINCE 1960, SO IT WAS
COMPLETE THE RIDICULOUS.
IT WAS ALSO USED TO MAKE SURE
THAT COMPETITORS WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO GET INTO THE RACE.
WELL, DEMOCRACY IS TO LET
EVERYONE BECOME A CANDIDATE, SO
WE LET THE PEOPLE DECIDE, AND
NOT A GROUP OF PEOPLE SIT IN A
ROOM AND DECIDE WHO SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CONTEST.
SO, THE NEW CONSTITUTION GIVES
A FULL OPENNESS TO CANDIDACY
WHEN PEOPLE WANT TO RUN FOR
OFFICE.
SO, THESE ARE SOME OF THE
ELEMENTS THAT I WANTED TO GIVE
ON THESE QUESTIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HIS EXCELLENCY, I THANK YOU
FOR A GOOD PRESENTATION.
MY NAME IS JOB YOUR UMBRELLA.
I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN. I AM
A SOPHOMORE AT COLUMBIA COLLEGE
SO I ACTUALLY HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS, FIRSTLY, YOU TALKED
ABOUT HOW THERE ARE PROBLEMS IN
AFRICAN COUNTRIES IN TERMS OF
ECONOMIC INTEGRATION, AND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD
ELABORATE MORE ABOUT SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS WHICH AFRICAN
COUNTRIES FACE. YOU DON'T HAVE
TO REALLY GO INTO THE DETAILS
ABOUT THE NAMES OF COUNTRIES,
AND ALSO, I WANTED TO KNOW ONE
OF THE BEST THINGS WHICH YOU
CAN SAY WHICH PEOPLE SHOULD
KNOW ABOE D'IVOIRE, SO
LIKE -- YET.
THANK YOU.
THE BESTE HING ABOUT CC
D'IVOIRE.
YES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MY NAME IS IDRIS, AND I'M A
PHD STUDENT IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HISTORY WITH MY FRIEND AHMED
IN THE BACK.
WE ARE ONE OF THE IVORIAN
STUDENTS HERE AT COLUMBIA, AND
I APOLOGIZE, I JUST FOUND OUT
THAT THIS WAS HAPPENING, SEEING
THE DELEGATIONS VEHICLES
OUTSIDE, SO I AM NOT VERY WELL
PREPARED.
BUT, MY QUESTION, YOU MENTIONED
THAT A LOT OF THE BASES FOR
IVORY COAST'S CURRENT SUCCESS
ECONOMICALLY WAS FOUNDED UNDER
-- BUT, YOU MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN THE
COUNTRY UNDERWENT BETWEEN 2000
AND 2010 HAVE DEEPER ROOTS IN
HISTORY, SO MY QUESTION IS WHAT
LESSONS DO YOU THINK WE MUST
DRAW FROM EXPERIENCE OVER THE
FIRST 40 AND 50 YEARS OF
INDEPENDENCE, AND WHAT HAVE YOU
DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
MISTAKES ARE NOT REPEATED IN
THE FUTURE?
THANK YOU.
>> YOU HAVE A QUESTION ALSO?
>> THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND THANK YOU PROFESSOR DIOUF,
YOU ARE ACTUALLY MY PROFESSOR
THIS SEMESTER.
I AM TAKING HIS CLASS OF AFRICA
BEFORE COLONIALISM.
MY NAME IS UPSON OKA, AND I AM
A FORMER PROFESSIONAL SOCCER
PLAYER.
I REPRESENT THE COUNTRY OF
IVORY COAST MANY TIMES.
COLUMBIA GAVE ME A SECOND
CHANCE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL, SO
I AM A SENIOR AT THE SCHOOL OF
GENERAL STUDIES.
I AM STUDYING FINANCIAL
ECONOMICS. I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS
MISTER PRESIDENT. THE FIRST ONE,
IS ABOUT ECONOMICS. IT IS NOT A
SECRET THAT THE CHINESE ECONOMY
IS MOVING FROM THE
MANUFACTURING STAGE TO THE
SERVICE STAGE, THIS MEANS THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AFRICAN
COUNTRIES TO ATTRACT ALL OF
THESE INVESTMENTS AND CREATE
JOBS.
FOR EXAMPLE, ETHIOPIA IS
ALREADY BENEFITING FROM THESE
OPPORTUNITIES.
WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS, OR WHAT
ARE YOU PLANNING TO DO FOR
IVORY COAST IN ORDER TO ATTRACT
THIS INVESTMENT, AND CREATE
JOBS.
THE SECOND QUESTION IS NOT
REALLY A QUESTION, AS YOU CAN
SEE, WE ARE MANY IVORIANS GOING
TO SCHOOL IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT IS A GREAT COUNTRY WHERE WE
ARE LEARNING A LOT, A LOT OF
SKILLS.
FROM COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY, I
GAINED FROM EXPERIENCE IN
INVESTMENT BANKING, AND ALSO
SOME ESPERANCE AND CORPORATE
FINANCE.
WORKING FOR DIFFERENT
CORPORATIONS.
WE LOVE OUR COUNTRY, AND WE
WANT TO HELP DEVELOPING
COUNTRIES.
WHAT ARE YOU PLANNING TO HELP
US GO BACK AND HAVE A COUNTRY?
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT, AND
THANK YOU PROFESSOR DIOUF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
CONCERNING ECONOMIC INTEGRATION,
WELL OBVIOUSLY, ONE CAN SPEND A
LOT OF TIME DEVELOPING THIS,
BUT WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS
-- BECAUSE, CLEARLY, THERE IS
POLITICAL WEIGHT, AND ALSO,
COUNTRIES HAVE GOODS TO TRADE
WITH EACH OTHER, AND I THINK
THERE IS ALSO A GOOD ENVIRONMENT
WHERE, YOU HAVE A GOOD
DEMOCRATIC ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK THIS HELPS IN TERMS OF
SETTING RULES, AND ABIDING BY
THEM AND SO FORTH.
SO, IT IS NOT EASY, I WOULD
SAY, BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE SEE
THAT ONEE THER COUNTRY, CC
D'IVOIRE FOR EXAMPLE, HAS BEEN
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS AND
WANTS TO EXPORT GOODS, TO SOME
OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT REQUIRES THAT WE SEND OUR
MINISTERS TO CONVINCE OUR
PARTNERS THAT THIS IS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
RULES.
AND, NATIONALS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES CAN COME AND WORK
EASILY IE D'IVOIRE.
SIGH.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
IVORIANS TO WORK IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
SO, YOU HAVE TO HAVE A WAY TO
GET THE ENVIRONMENT IN TERMS OF
RULES AND INTEGRATIONS
COORDINATED TO MAKE THEM FAIR
IN TERMS OF ACCESS TO EVERYONE.
SO, IT IS NOT AN EASY THING TO
DO. IN WEST AFRICA, ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES WE HAD IS THAT AMONG
THE 15 COUNTRIES, EIGHT ALREADY
ARE IN AN ECONOMIC AND MILITARY
UNION.
THEY HAVE THE SAME LEGAL
FRAMEWORK AND SO FORTH.
SO, THE SAME LANGUAGE, AND THIS
HAS FACILITATED THINGS.
AND THEN, YOU HAVE NIGERIA,
WHICH IS A COUNTRY BY ITSELF, A
CONTINENT I WOULD SAY BY
ITSELF, AND SO FORTH, SO.
YOU HAVE THE SAME THING IN THE
SOUTHERN GROUP WITH SOUTH AFRICA
BEING AN ENGINE.
SO, IF YOU HAVE ENGINES OF REAL
INTEGRATION, IT CAN WORK, AND
CC
E D'IVOIRE HAS BEEN AN
ENGINE FOR INTEGRATION BY
ABSORBING THE POPULATION OF
OTHER COUNTRIES.
NOW, YOU SAID WHAT IS THE BEST
THING ABE D'IVOIRE?
I SAID IT IT -- I WOULD SAY IT
IS HOSPITALITY, REALLY.
IVORIANS ARE KNOWN TO BE
HOSPITABLE PEOPLE, SO, THIS IS
-- YOU CE D'IVOIRE
AND SPEND A FEW DAYS, AND YOU
WILL SEE THAT PEOPLE ARE NICE
AND GOOD PEOPLE.>> [ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
AND IDRIS HAS SAID THAT I
TALKED ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE DONE
IN THE ECONOMIC FIELD BUT
CLEARLY SOME OF THE POLITICAL
PROBLEMS THAT WE INHERITED WAS
OF MY PREDECESSORS DOING.
AND I AGREE.
FOR FOUR DECADES, WE HAD A ONE
PARTY SYSTEM, AND SO FORTH, AND
I THINK THE LESSON I WILL DRAW
FROM THAT IS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE DEMOCRACY.
AND, FAIR ELECTIONS. AND, TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE WEALTH OF
YOUR COUNTRY, TO THE PROBLEMS
OF YOUR COUNTRY, TO MAKING A
CONTRIBUTION TO THE COUNTRY.
SO CLEARLY, I THINK THIS IS THE
IDEA OF THE NEW CONSTITUTION
THAT WE HAVE SET UP, TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT FORCES IN A WAY OF
POLITICAL INTEGRATION, WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME, IT GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE TO
COMPETE.
AND, IF YOUR COMPETITION IS
FAIR, THE PEOPLE WILL DECIDE.
AND, I THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT
THAT SOMEONE DOES NOT PICK ONE
PERSON AS A RULER OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND UPSET OKA MENTIONED THAT
THE CHINESE COUNTRY AND THE
ECONOMY AND PERFORMANCE OF
CHINESE INVESTMENTS IN AFRICA,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
RECOGNIZE, AND WE ARE WORKING
VERY WELL WITH THE CHINESE IN
TERMS OF SETTING UP
MANUFACTURING INVESTMENTS IN
CC
E D'IVOIRE.
IT IS IMPORTANT.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE PRODUCE COCOA,
BUT WE PROCESS ONLY ONE THIRD
OF OUR COCOA PRODUCTION.
TWO THIRDS WE HAVE SENT OUTSIDE
WITH AN -- WITHOUT ANY
PROCESSING.
SO I TALKED TO THE CHINESE AND
I SAID WHY DON'T YOU COME AND
SIT -- SENT MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRIES TO TRANSFORM INTO
COCOA BUTTER AND COCOA PASTE,
AND THEN SEND THEM TO CHINA, IF
YOU WANT, TO PRODUCE CHOCOLATE
FOR THE CHINESE.
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON, AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
VIETNAMESE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
AREA OF CASHEW NUTS.
WE PRODUCE MORE THAN 700,000
TONS OF CASHEW NUTS, MORE THAN
INDIA, WE ARE THE FIRST
PRODUCER.
BUT, WE PRODUCE ONLY 8% OF THE
CASHEW NUTS, SO WE ARE
ENCOURAGING THEM TO SEND
INDUSTRIES TO PROCESS CASHEW
NUTS AND SO FORTH.
I THINK THERE IS A GOOD
POSSIBILITY FOR HAVING THE
CHINESE SET UP INDUSTRIES IN
OUR COUNTRY.
I WOULD END IN THE U.S., YOU
KNOW, EVERY TIME I TRAVEL TO A
COUNTRY, I HAVE THE MINISTER OF
MINISTRATION WITH ME. I USED TO
MEET WITH THE IVORIANS, ON AN
OFFICIAL VISIT.
THIS IS NOT AN OFFICIAL VISIT,
BUT EVERYWHERE WE GO, WE MEET
WITH A VARIANCE AND TELL THEM,
WELL, YOU ARE STARTING HERE,
YOU ARE WORKING HERE, IN
ENGLAND, FRANCE, SPAIN,
PORTUGAL, IN TURKEY. WHEN YOU
FINISH, E ME BACK TO CC
D'IVOIRE.
BECAUSE IT IS A GROWING
ECONOMY, IT HAS A COUNTRY -- IT
IS A COUNTRY THAT HAS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL, AND YOU HAVE
INDUSTRIES FROM ALL OF THOSE
COUNTRIES SETTING UP OFFICES IN
CC
E D'IVOIRE.
IF THEY SPEAK CHINESE, THERE IN
CHINA BUT USUALLY WHEN THEY GO
BACK TO E D'IVOIRE THEY WILL
FIND A JOB EASILY IN A CHINESE
COMPANY.
SO.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A FORMER
SOCCER PLAYER, AND I HAVE
ANOTHER FRIEND WHO IS A FORMER
SOCCER PLAYER, WAY OF LIBERIA
WAS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENTIAL
OFFICE IN OCTOBER.
SO GOOD LUCK TO THE FUTURE.
>> I AM VERY SORRY, WE DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME.
THE ONLY THING I CAN DO IS TAKE
ONE MAN AND ONE WOMAN.
OKAY, I WILL TAKE THIS INSIDE A
WOMAN, AND THIS SIDE AMEN.
FOR THE REST, I'M REALLY SORRY.
WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
>> HI AT YOUR EXCELLENCY, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SPEECH.
BOTH OF MY PARENTS ARE FROM
CC
E D'IVOIRE, AND THEY CA
HERE AND I AM THE SECOND CHILD
THEY HAD HERE.
MY DAD ALWAYS TALK TO ME ABOUT
GOING TO IVORY COAST AND BEING
AN AMBASSADOR, BUT WE WILL SEE.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS, IDRIS
TALKED ABOUT HOW A LOT OF
IVORIANS COME HERE TO PURSUE
THEIR EDUCATION.
I WAS JUST WONDERING IF YOU
HAVE ANY PLANS TO IMPROVE THE
EDUCATIOE D'IVOIRE SO
THAT IVORIANS CAN STAY THERE
AND HELP THE COUNTRY OUT, AND
THAT'S IT.
>> YES, I THINK THE SECOND -- >>
THANK YOU YOUR EXCELLENCY.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO US
TODAY.
MY NAME IS MO DO, I AM
ORIGINALLY FROM WEST AFRICA,
AND I AM STUDYING
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGEMENT.
AT THE SCHOOL OF PROFESSIONAL
STUDIES.
YOU MENTE D'IVOIRE'S
ENERGY CAPACITY, AND THE FACT
THAT THE GOAL IS TO DOUBLE IT
BY 2020.
THE GOAL -- DEVELOPING
SUSTAINABLE GOALS IN 2020 AND
DEVELOPS HIS DAILY.
ARE YOU PLANNING TO UPHOLD THAT
PROMISE AND DEVELOP THE ENERGY
SECTOR SUSTAINABLY CARE --?
ALONG WITH THE GOAL OF
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY FOR ALL.
THANK YOU.
>> ALONG THE QUESTION OF
STUDENTS COMING HERE TO STUDY,
I THINK MISTER COHEN --
MINISTER TONGA AND MYSELF WERE
AMONG THE FIRST STUDENTS TO
COME TO THE U.S. TO STUDY.
IN THE EARLY 60s.
SINCE THEN, OF COURSE, MANY OF
THEM HAVE COME, AND I THINK
THAT SO MANY HAVE RETURNED TO
CC
E D'IVOIRE.
AND, YOU ARE RIGHT TO SAY WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO IMPROVE
EDUCATION AND HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS E D'IVOIRE.
SO THAT STUDENTS CAN STUDY IN
CC
E D'IVOIRE AS WELL.
BUT, THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
YOU SEE, WHEN I REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS PRIME MINISTER, FROM 90 TO
93, THERE WERE NO -- THERE WAS
ONE UNIVERSITY.
BUT IN THREE YEARS I WAS ABLE
TO SET UP A SECOND UNIVERSITY,
AND NOW WHEN WE CAME BACK IN
2011, THE UNIVERSITIES WERE NOT
FUNCTIONING AT ALL.
IT WAS USED FOR THINGS OTHER
THAN STUDYING.
AND DROVE TRACK TO TRAFFICKING
AND REALLY A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
WE HAVE SET UP THREE MORE
UNIVERSITIES, AND OBVIOUSLY,
THIS PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE. OUR
OBJECTIVE IS BY 2022 HAVE
REGIONAL DISTRICTS. WE HAVE 10
DISTRICTE D'IVOIRE, AND
I THINK CLEARLY, IF THE COCOA
SHOCK CAN BE CONTAINED, THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE 8 TO 10
UNIVERSIE D'IVOIRE
BY 2020.
TODAY WE HAVE FIVE, SO WE HAVE
TWO OR THREE MORE TO DO BEFORE
THEN.
HE ALSO E OUDLY NOTE THAT CC
D'IVOIRE HAS ONE OF THE BEST
HIGHER EDUCATION SCHOOLS, THE
INSTITUTE POLYTECHNIC AND THE
LIKE, AND THIS YEAR I AM
PLANNING TO GO TO FRENCH
POLYTECHNIC SCHOOLS, I THINK
OUT OF SEVEN AFRICANS WHO WERE
RECRUITED, I CAN BE CORRECTED I
THINK FIVE OF THEM WERE FROM
CC
E D'IVOIRE.
SO WE ARE ENSURING THAT THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION HAS QUITE
IMPROVEDE D'IVOIRE.
OF COURSE, MANY STUDENTS ARE
COMING HERE, AND I THINK THIS A
CHANGE IS GOOD.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD JUST
DEVELOP E IVERSITIES IN CC
D'IVOIRE AND CLOSE DOWN ON
IVORIANS, AND NOT LET THEM HAVE
THE CHANCE TO GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES, TO SENEGAL, TO
FRANCE, TO THE U.S..
NOW, ON THE QUESTION OF ENERGY.
CLEARLY WE ARE COMMITTED TO
THAT, BUT WE ARE DOING QUITE
WELL.
ACCESS IE UP 80% IN CC
D'IVOIRE AND WE ARE HAVING GOOD
PERFORMANCE.
SO WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
REACH THESE GOALS.
PROFESSOR, YOU HAD MENTIONED,
YOU HAD DECIDED THAT YOU WANTED
ME TO TALK ABOUT THE FRANK I
THINK, AND ANOTHER POINT YOU
SAID, LET ME TALK ABOUT THE
FRANK.
YOU HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE COMMON CURRENCY.
BUT, I THINK YOU HAVE ALL
STUDIED. OVER THE PAST FEW
DECADES, THE FIGHT TO HAVE A
COMMON CURRENCY IN WEST AFRICA
AND IN CENTRAL AFRICA HAS BEEN
A GOOD THING, GLOBALLY.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS ALL DEPENDS ON
THE TYPE OF POLICIES THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES INTIMATE.
AND, I WAS A GOVERNOR OF OUR
COMMON CENTRAL BANK MYSELF, I
WAS IN SERVICE OF THE
PROFESSOR, YOU SAID, AND THEN
GOVERNOR. AND, WE TRIED TO
IMPROVE NOT ONLY THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE BANK BUT ALSO THE
MONETARY POLICY OF THE BANK.
I REMEMBER THAT WE WERE
IMPLEMENTING A MONETARY FORECAST
TO TRY TO CALCULATE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY SUPPLY WE SHOULD HAVE
PUT OUT BEFORE THE BANK OF
FRANCE, YOU SEE.
SO PEOPLE HAVE THIS PERVERSE
IDEA THAT WE ARE GETTING
EVERYTHING FROM FRANCE, BUT THE
CENTRAL BANK HAS REALLY BEEN IN
A FOREIGN INSTITUTION.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT IF WE DID
NOT HAVE THIS COMMON CURRENCY,
IN THE 1990S, WE WOULD HAVE HAD
AN ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE.
THE FACT THAT IT IS A COMMON
MANAGEMENT CURRENCY GIVES THE
PRESSURE ON THE AUTHORITIES,
THE NATIONAL AUTHORITIES TO
IMPLEMENT GOOD FINANCIAL AND
BUDGET POLICIES.
IN FACT, I HAD LUNCH WITH
PRESIDENT MARK ON IN FRANCE, AND
I WAS TELLING HIM, IF WE HAD A
NATIONALE ENTRAL BANK IN CC
D'IVOIRE, WE ARE DROPPING THE
PRICE OF COCOA, AS A
POLITICIAN, MY FIRST SENTENCE
WOULD HAVE BEEN TO DEVALUE, SO
THAT I CONTINUE TO GIVE THE
FARMERS THE SAME PRICE.
GIVE THEM MONEY ILLUSION, AND
NOT TAKE THE DIFFICULT MEASURE
OF REDUCING THE DOMESTIC PRICE
OF COCOA.
BUT THAT IS WHAT WE DID, WE
REDUCED THE DOMESTIC PRICE OF
COCOA, AND THIS ALLOWED
INFLATION TO BE CONTAINED, AND
ALSO GAVE COMPENSATION TO OTHER
SECTORS.
SO, GLOBALLY, WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ON
THE CFA FRANC, BUT I DON'T
THINK THIS IS SO BAD, AND I
THINK WE SHOULD TRY TO HAVE A
LARGER MONETARY AREA. WE HOPE
TO INCLUDE OTHER COUNTRIES,
BECAUSE THE LARGER THE AREA IS
-- AFTER ALL, PEOPLE FORGET,
THE UNITED STATES, YOU
CIRCULATE THE DOLLAR IN NEW
YORK, OR COLORADO OR FLORIDA,
BUT IS -- IT IS THE SAME THING
THAT WE SHOULD DO.
AND IN EUROPE, I HEAR PEOPLE
SAY WHY DON'T YOU HAVE YOUR OWN
CURRENCY? FRENCH -- FRANCE HAD
THE FRENCH FRONT.
AND TODAY THEY HAD THE EURO.
WHICH CIRCULATES IN FRANCE AND
GERMANY AND SPAIN, BUT THAT
DOES NOT MAKE IT ABOUT
CURRENCY.
THE MAIN THING IS, THE DOMESTIC
NATIONAL POLICIES HAVE TO BE
CONVERGENT, HAVE TO BE
SUSTAINABLE, AND THEY HAVE TO
BE IN CONFORMITY WITH DOMESTIC
NEEDS.
TO FINISH ON THIS, I WOULD SAY
THAT IT WAS WHEN I WAS GOVERNOR
WHEN I INDICATED TO THE HEAD OF
STATES THAT WE HAD A BAD
MONETARY POLICY AT THAT TIME,
IN THE LATE 80s.
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAD AN
ECONOMIC INTEGRATION, BUT THEY
HAD A PROBLEM SETTING UP THE
MONETARY UNION, SO I TOLD
PRESIDENT DIOUF, LOOK, AND SINCE
WE HAD A DIFFICULT -- ECONOMIC
DIFFICULTIES, WHY DON'T WE HAVE
A UNION, SO WE THAT -- THAT IS
HOW WE SET UP THE ECONOMIC
UNION OF NORTH AFRICA OF AFRICA.
-- THE ECONOMIC UNION OF
AFRICA.
THANK YOU.
>> [ APPLAUSE ].
>> BEFORE CONCLUDING, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND
OUR STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
PRESENT AND HAVE ASKED
EXCELLENT QUESTIONS, WHICH IS A
TESTIMONY OF THE EDUCATION
COLUMBIA IS GIVING THEM.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
PRESIDENT OUATTARA FOR HIS
THOUGHTFUL PRESENTATION, FOR
BOTH DISCUSSING THE PRESENT AND
FUTURE OF THE CONTINENT,
HIGHLIGHTING THE TRAJECTORIES OF
WEST AFRICA, AND OF THE IVORY
COAST, WHICH HAS REALLY ENABLED
A FRANK CONVERSATION.
IN PARTICULAR, I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK HIM FOR DISCUSSING AT THE
END, THE CFA FRANC.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MANY
AFRICANS ARE INTERESTED IN IS
THE IVORY COAST IS DEVELOPING
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE IF
OUR INEXPERIENCE HAS BEEN SINCE
THE PRICE -- THE CRISIS.
I THINK MUCH CAN BE LEARNED
FROM THAT CRISIS, AND I THINK
REFLECTION ON THE EXPERIENCE IS
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL FOR THE
PROGRESS OF DEMOCRACY IN
AFRICA.
AND THE PROGRESS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVERSATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM
BECAUSE IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
FOR A POLITICIAN TO KNOW THE
FACTS.
I AM GLAD THAT HE KNOWS THE
FACT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
>> THANK YOU PROFESSOR,
LIKEWISE, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU, FOR INVITING ME TO THE
WORLD LEADERS FORUM, AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
STUDENTS AS WELL HERE WHO HAVE
TAKEN THE TIME TO COME AND
LISTEN TO ME.
I WAS REALLY QUITE
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN MY
PRESENTATION, AND IN TALKING
TRUTHFULE D'IVOIRE.
WE HAVE MADE GOOD PROGRESS, IT
IS TRUE, AND WE HAVE MADE
MISTAKES ALSO, AND I THINK THAT
CLEARLY, THAT IS A CHALLENGE
FOR ALL OF US, BUT IN
PARTICULARLY IS IN PARTICULAR
FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE.
YOU ARE THE NEXT LEADERS OF
CC
E D'IVOIRE, OF AFRICA,
OF YOUR COUNTRIES.
AND I BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOU TO AT SOME STAGE GO
BACK TO AFRICA, TO YOUR
COUNTRIES, TO HELP, BECAUSE THE
EXPERIENCE IN UNIVERSITIES LIKE
COLUMBIA AND PENNSYLVANIA AND
HARVARD ARE QUITE ENORMOUS FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR CONTINENT,
AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
TIME THAT I SPENT, TO LISTEN TO
WHAT I HAVE TO SAY.
GOOD NIGHT TO ALL OF US.
THANK YOU.>> [ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.